hey guys i'm amy lee from evanescence
and i'm here with buzzfeed
to take the quiz to find out which
classic alt rock band
i am i don't know what's going to happen
but i have a good feeling that i
might not be myself so let's find out
all right question one first things
first how would
your closest friends describe your sense
of humor
okay provocative dad-like sarcastic
deadpan i wish witty or self-deprecating
self-deprecating for sure unfortunately
that's very true which of these records
are you buying at sam goody
i miss going there love angel music baby
by gwen stefani
american idiot by green day hot fuss by
the killers
favorite worst nightmare by arctic
monkeys
green album by weezer it's blitz by the
eis
okay i love american idiot but that's
not my green day album
my green day album is dookie i do love
that gwen stefani album and i
do really like the yeah yeah yes all
right i'll go with gwen
doing it chicks roll pick a lyric for
your next
instagram caption if there's no one
beside you when your soul embarks then
i'll follow you into the dark depth cab
love it i'm a hostage to my own humanity
rely okay
i'm an addict for dramatics i confuse
the two for love
taking back sunday there's a story at
the bottom of this bottle all
time low now there's no place i'd rather
be than here in your arms hello goodbye
have you ever been alone in a crowded
room jack's mannequin
i i gotta go with the first one
obviously i love deathcab
for doing it i don't know how this is
going so far i'm not nervous
but you should be if you could only be
the master of one instrument what would
it be oh
guitar bass drums piano synthesizer or
vocals
only one
i can't if i pick what i already
do that's boring i like singing
i like synthesizer i like piano i've
always wanted to be a bass player
i'm picking bass all right you're on a
long drive to nowhere which playlist are
you listening to
i love this question pop punk powerhouse
i am the main character
songs to scream in the shower
[Music]
[Laughter]
macabre film scores yes mood booster
acoustic coffee shop um i'm on a long
drive
um okay film scores that's me that's
just who i truly am
it's not an act pick an accessory from
your youth
black nail polish wearing it now studded
belt
i'm not wearing it now but i have
several fishnet fingerless gloves that's
totally over
doc martens got em duct tape wallet
awesome
a non-load piercing had that too shoot
all right my youth accessory
i'll go with the piercing i had more
than you know of
finally which shade of black brings you
to life
okay ebony onyx midnight
inc raven or obsidian
oh these are awesome midnight's sort of
blue ink is kind of
indigo raven what's the blackest
probably onyx and they had a cool song
all right here we go
paramore that makes some sense
i mean i like paramore
look how cute she is despite what your
discography says
you're anything but misery business in
fact with your array of pop punk anthems
and melodic love songs
what pop punk did i pick okay death cab
kind of and melodic love songs
you and your vibrant red hair i did have
it once
are the only exception you are
the only exception
love it sweet thanks i'm cooler than i
thought i was
thanks for hanging out with me i enjoyed
this quiz i hope you enjoy it too
which classic alt rock band are you
we'll see you soon we're going on tour
with hailstorm this november
be there
[Music]
you